desafortunadamente No no ha habido
justicia ni reparación de hecho lo que
haya habido aquí es una extensa
impunidad le comento que de las más de
10.800 causas de víctimas que fueron
judicializadas hoy día tenemos solamente
16 sentencias condenatorias Lo que
implica que solo un 1% de esas causas
hoy día se encuentra finalizada y lo que
es peor es que en los saltos mandos que
fueron responsables de la implementación
de esta estrategia represora no se
encuentran ni siquiera en calidad de
imputados no han sido investigado por lo
tanto no han rendido cuentas hacia la
ciudadanía sobre esos actos represivos
Sofía ustedes también demandan una serie
de cambios a la institución de
carabineros cuáles son esas solicitudes
bueno entre esas son las medidas de
reparación y efectivamente lo que
nosotros estamos solicitando entre otras
cosas es una reestructuración profunda a
la institución de carabineros no
solamente algo cosmético sino que deben
revisarse todas las leyes normas
decretos regla que constituyen y que
eligen la organización de carabineros
tiene que reformularse de forma que
desde desde la formación de los
oficiales y de todo el personal de
carabinero tengan en el centro de esa
Academia
y restricto respeto a los Derechos
Humanos ahora cómo evalúan los esfuerzos
del gobierno actual para crear garantías
de respeto a los Derechos Humanos
nosotros vemos Que ha habido avances si
comparamos este gobierno con el anterior
una de las cosas importantes que el
actual gobierno reconoció la ocurrencia
de la violación en los Derechos Humanos
cosa que el Antiguo gobierno se negaba
sistemáticamente a reconocer y además
condena
radicalmente tales hechos lo cual
constituye un inicio bastante importante
también han habido avances en relación
al programa para poder asistir a las
víctimas de sobre todo las víctimas de
trauma ocular se está desarrollando una
característica de reparación que tiene
distintos componentes y que es mucho más
integral y mucho más completa en
comparación al programa que existía en
el gobierno anterior lo cual nosotros
miramos con bastante buenos ojos